it can get scary I mean that level of
fame I'm thinking you starred in five
movies it was a seven years stretch you
were nominated for Best Picture LA
Confidential right the insider gladiator
A Beautiful Mind mm-hmm everybody's
favorite film and Master and Commander
so you have this role you become more
more famous but after gladiator I
believe you get a call from the FBI and
they say there's I still don't
understand all that man I mean you don't
know I arrive at a hotel I had a message
there's a dude from the FBI wants to
have a chat he comes in he goes you know
for the next little while we're gonna be
with you is that what does that mean
with me yeah so everywhere I went for
you know that's part of the year and
stuff there was always cars around
because al-qaeda they had picked up a
threat that al-qaeda because you were
such a big star against al-qaeda
targeted you or picked up some
conversation yeah yeah but you know what
I don't know
right you know I mean it was coming I
just wanted to hang out with Russell
Crowe maybe maybe they realized I was
gonna pick up the bar tab I don't right
no that's a tough life on a government
salary no I don't know what that was but
yeah so this is 9/11 and you didn't even
Al Qaeda was you were like al Qaeda it
wants me who is al Qaeda's director or
is that from my memory of it what they
said was this somebody in Algiers had
been over her by a French policewoman or
something you know not over but like
listening on and there was some broader
plot which was about kidnapping public
figures oh well
Wow hey did you walk around like
paranoid but the FBI would I mean how
nice they actually kind of hung with you
and made sure you didn't get kidnapped
yeah and then one day they weren't there
anymore right really with you I mean you
got to know them wild